est-ce que là ça claque pas un peu avec
un petit verre de rioja
de l'autre côté le coucher de soleil il
fait beau il fait chaud on est en
espagne sans l'atlantique vous emmène
pendant quatre jours avec moi on est
aussi de ses vies on entre séville et
faro pour une conférence des conférences
sur l'iph alors là me voyant les thèmes
sur le sable c'est relativement sympa
[Musique]
il est très très très tôt il est quelle
heure il est 7 heures 13 aujourd'hui
j'ai trois avions trois avions je suis
ça pourrait être intéressant tester un
casque à l'adduction bruit justement il
ya un nouveau casque de hackage et c'est
le n700 nc casque à réduction de bruit
et si vous regardez bien les petit
pictogramme est bon pour le train bon
pack 3 aujourd'hui mais pour l'avion et
comme je vous dis j'en ai trois comme ça
on va se tester et je vais vous dire si
intéressante ou non est juste avant on
va se regarder un petit peu ce qu'il ya
dans la boîte
alors on va se faire ça de façon un
petit peu sommaire est très rapide parce
que j'ai pas trop trop trop de temps
très très grosse voix d'un design très
sympa la boîte est assez grosse alors à
cacher été rachetée va sans dessous et
vous avez l'étui c'est vachement sympa
ici le casque à l'intérieur ici voliez
marqué accessories ils vous ont maîtrisé
accessoires vous avez un accessoire ça
c'est pour recharger en micro usb vers
usb vous avez si la petite prise pour le
mettre dans les avions ici c'est jack
jack pour le brancher si toutefois vous
avez des problèmes de batterie ça c'est
cool
manuel d'utilisation est ici vous avez
le casque dans son étui assez gros bien
pliés avec une petite pochette pour
déranger tous les accessoires
si vous le voulez maintenant direction
l'aéroport et on s'envole
je vais le tester et du groupe haraki
mon casque que j'utilise personnellement
c'est le sony w/h nixon trois et je vous
dirai si ce haka gn 700 c'est
intéressant et qu'en est il par rapport
à son concurrent principal
mais
[Musique]
premier arrêt on est à l'aéroport de
paris-orly faudra descendre un peu plus
au sud en faisant ça j'ai déjà testé sur
une partie du voyage j'ai déjà testé
hier
ce casque de saccager à kg n700 ncn
scène noise cancelling réduction de
bruit on va déjà faire un petit tour un
peu du casque alors si vous voyez bien
sûr le dessus tout ça c'est du plastique
le côté c'est du plastique bon dans
l'absolu ça me choque absolument pas
tout ça c'est réglable c'est un arceau
en acier ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal
quand même sensation de robustesse voulu
régler jusqu'à 11 en fonction de votre
tête
alors bon ça dépend de votre texte vous
avez une très très grande moi j'ai pas
eu ni pas grande pète ça marche plutôt
bien déjà quand vous le posez comme ça
sa ferme un peu ça isole ce qui est cool
sont les coussinets mémoire de forme on
a une sensation de confort vous avez la
forme là il ya une espèce de c'est pas
un rond à la différence du casque de
sonim on comparera tout à l'heure on
regardera la différence parce que
j'utilise donc je connais vachement bien
il vient bien tenir vos oreilles vous
les envoie tes biens et des jardins
comme ça mécaniquement ça bloque
ça tire les oreilles c'est pas mal vous
avez sur le côté droit
le bouton qui sert à l'allumer à
l'éteindre et lorsque vous le coucher un
peu plus bas ça va activer le bluetooth
au pouvoir l'appareil est ici vous le
recharger en micro usb
ça c'est le bouton pour régler la
réduction de bruit vous avez de l'autre
côté ici bouton pour monter le volume
pour le bc souhaite un appui prolongé là
ça va passer au morceau suivant pareil
appui prolongé la vous revenez au
morceau d'avant et ici vous allez activé
lecture pause et vous allez pouvoir lors
des appels raccrocher décrocher et sur
le bouton là si vous faites
deux appuis ça vous activez google
assistant vous le voyez sur écoute et
vous avez un petit micro pour la
réduction de bruit vous avez son petit
frère qui est juste là en gros ce qu'ils
vont faire c est qui vont capter le son
environnement et ils vont réduire le
bruit donc déjà rien comme ça en termes
de fabrication je trouve bien plutôt pas
mal
il est un peu plus lourd que le sony whl
big sam 3 je le trouve un peu moins bien
en termes de confort ça tient à pas
grand chose maintenant on va continuer
paris madrid en faire une petite halte
madrid sait lire et à la fin ce sera d
horizon complet vient d'arriver je vous
emmène avec moi pour quelques jours a
sévi enfin au sud de ces vies on est
tout en bas on entre séville et faro le
spot c'est barcelo punta umbria billy
ray sol voilà je pars très très mal avec
mon espagnol on est là pour quelques
jours pour parler de l'ief alors l'ifas
un salon grand public technologique qui
a lieu au mois de septembre
chaque année début septembre en gros le
salon qui ouvre la rentrée donc cela
pour quelques jours voir un peu les
nouveautés technologiques et compagnie
et justement j'ai profité de mon voyage
en avion j'ai trois avions aujourd'hui
je vous parlais de ce petit casque dans
ce cas ce que là il est vachement
intéressant pour plusieurs raisons la
toute première c'est que vous avez la
signature à kg alors je pas si vous
connaissez à kg ha kg a été racheté par
harman kardon
samsung a racheté harman kardon donc en
gros samsung a racheté à kg c'est pour
ça que dans toutes les boîtes de
smartphones samsung pour trouver des
casques à kg et celui là est vachement
intéresseront pourquoi déjà parce
qu'elles craignent que son bruit qui est
pas mal
alors je les compare et moi au sony wlh
1000 x m3 qui est le modèle le plus haut
de gamme de chez sony
au niveau réduction de bruit il ya une
petite différence au niveau des
fréquences qui sont coupés vous entendez
à l'oreille dans l'avion par exemple
vous avez un son qui est un peu plus en
plus c'est du trois fois rien ce qui est
vraiment bien avec ce casque à la
différence du casque sony c'est la
signature audio vous avez un vrai son
type est un vrai sont signés à kg ça
c'est vraiment intéressant et c'est pour
moi le point fort de ce casque et je
trouve vraiment très intéressant vous
avez deux modes pour l'écouter le
premier mode c'est avec et la réduction
de bruit le deuxième mode c'est les
micros qui vont être activés pour
entendre ce qui se passe autour de vous
ça c'est aussi intéressant et ça vous
tient vraiment éveillé par rapport à ce
qui se passe autour vous notamment quand
vous allez courir fait
ron ça vous évite de chuter une bagnole
quoi que ce soit au moins comme ça vous
êtes au courant vous avais prévenu ça
c'est plutôt pas mal
donc ça c'est pour le côté audio point
aussi intéressant vous pouvez faire
appel à google assistant donc lorsque
vous avez besoin de parler à google vous
poser une question
vous pouvez le faire vous pouvez tout
cas les là dessus pour aller moins loin
avec ce casque avec avec le sony w la
chute d'hier w/h melixon 3 par contre ça
vaut si une application vous pouvez
venir
quel est votre équaliseur c'est pas mal
au niveau audio devrait manquer les
leçons à votre oreille si vous voulez
plus de base + d'aigus creuse un peu les
médiums vous pouvez le faire
bon de base comme il est là il est
vraiment bien avec la signature odiouma
kg il vraiment vraiment intéressant côté
confort je préfère quand même le casque
de sonic et plus comme une grosse
pantoufles êtes hyper à l'aise lorsque
vous le donner celui là il vient bien
tenir votre oreille
mais du point de vue confort c'est pas
le cas ce que je vais préférer pareil
ici au niveau du confort c'est pas celui
que je préférais il fait le job mais
pour moi c'est pas le meilleur
autre point qui est hyper important avec
un casque à réduction de bruit vous
voulez que la réduction brute elle se
fasse dans les deux sens c'est à dire
que vous vous soyez cooper secouez votre
casque du milieu extérieur vous
entendiez pas ce qui arrive de
l'extérieur mais l'autre point qui est
intéressant c'est que lorsque vous avez
votre casque voulait pas forcément que
les gens autour de vous entendre ce que
vous entendez et là dessus
le n 7 100 m c est moins performante que
son cousin de chez sony
le w lâche 1103 qui empêche plus le son
de sortir et qui vous isole davantage
dans un sens comme dans l'autre
voilà celui là si vous êtes dans un lit
par exemple avec votre compagne votre
compagnon à côté de vous que vous avez
votre casque et bien la personne à côté
de vous entendra plus facilement ce
qu'ils sortent votre casque qui avec le
casque de sony ça c'est aussi un point
relativement intéressant ce que m'a dit
ma femme hier soir et médias sony là
j'entends un peu ce qui se passe dans
temple bruit et bon voilà c'est pas trop
mon truc c'est la envie de dormir à côté
c'est un peu la galère
bon il a aussi plein de points positifs
comme la fonctionnalité adaptative
réduction du som adaptatif en fonction
de l'environnement en gros il va en
permanence grâce au micro écouter ce qui
se passe autour de vous et réguler votre
réduction de bruit en fonction de ce qui
passe autour de vous
au niveau de l'autonomie alors moi je
n'ai pas mis à genoux un très clairement
à cacher nous annonce 20 heures en
autonomie avec la réduction de bruit en
bluetooth et trente six heures par
ailleurs addiction bruit lorsque vous
l'utilisez en filaire personnellement
j'ai pas mis à genoux un casque comme ça
pour le mettre à genoux
faut vraiment vouloir de toute façon
lorsque vous partez en voyage vous lui
mettez un petit coup de charges ça va
plutôt pas mal alors grosses différences
sociales de casque sony
ici vous avez de la recharge dans micro
usb alors que son casque sony vous avez
de la recharge en usb t-il si alors
attention pas de recharge rapide sur le
casque sony donc de ce point de vue là
c'est une question connectique mais pour
moi il n'y a pas de grosse grosse
différence par contre nos différences
qui est assez intéressante et qui est
notable entre les deux modèles c'est que
celui là n'a pas de pavé tactile
à la différence du casque de sonim où
vous avez un pavé tactile alors je
dirais que en gros les deux sont bons en
termes de réduction bruit les deux sont
bons celui là il est bon parce qu'elle
aussi une signature et un son qui plus
personnalisé que le que le casque sony
après ça dépendra de chacun et des goûts
et les couleurs ça ça dépend vraiment
vraiment vous c'est très personnel par
contre celui là pour moi
vu qu'on est quasiment même cause autour
des 350 euros il suffit pas tout à fait
dans la même cour la connectique c'est
pas tout à fait la même on n'a pas de
pavé tactile
bon voilà il ya quelques points qui font
la différence qui donne pour l'instant
le point au casque sony et le w achemine
xm3 donc ce qui serait vraiment bien
samsung a kg en tout cas peut-être plus
1 kg
si vous voulez que votre casque marche à
mon avis va falloir un petit peu revoir
la politique tarifaire et celle là
dessus à ce moment là qu'il va y avoir
de plus en plus de consommateurs qui
vont venir sur ce qu'est ce que la poste
que moi qu'un budget 350 euros mais son
casque de sony si par contre ce cas ce
que la passe en dessous de la barre des
300 euros il devient vraiment très
intéressant et je vous dis la réduction
de bruit l'audio sont bien donc bon
voilà c'est après une pointe de détails
mais quand on arrive à des buts chose
autour de 350 euros
ces détails ont vraiment de l'importance
autre plan déjà bien que ce cas c'est
que lorsque vous le portez comme ça
autour du cou voyez les écouteurs vers
l'avant comme en studio ça s'est un peu
l'héritage des studios moniteur trio da
kg
c'est à dire que chez d'autres
fabricants ça va être placé à
l'intérieur la situe dans cette position
pour vous puissiez écouter le son pour
qu'un ingénieur du son puis s'écouter
paf
il met son truc il écoute il a son ça
c'est plutôt pas mal bon voilà je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez de ce casque
est ce qui peut vous intéresser
je vous invite à me dire tout ce que
vous en pensez en dans commentaire est
ce que vous avez un casque à réduction
de bruit est ce que vous avez le casque
sony est ce que vous avez un casque de
bosses aussi qu'ils sont très très très
très bon dans ce domaine là et est ce
que ce casque de 1 kg pourrait vous
tentez voilà autres
le faire nous dit pas tout ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire je vous
emmène dans ma chambre
vous allez voir tu peux les coulisses
c'est juste dingue
vous allez voir l'ifa nous a vraiment
gâté on est vachement bien qu on est
juste au bord de la mer je vous emmène à
vous invite à vous abonner
comme ça je vous fait vivre toutes les
coulisses vous saurez tout la carte
regardez le truc de ouf regardez-moi ça
est ce qu'on n'est pas bien grande piol
la cei à 180 je suis tout seul jeu
relativement m'ennuyer lancé pas mal
vraiment la chambre est juste énorme
hyper hyper spacieuse regardé comme on
est bien reçu
salle de bain qui est caché justement
coin des miroirs de tous les côtés
c'est énorme et la grande baignoire tout
ce que j'ai voilà on est reçu comme des
rois
merci licha je vous invite à me dire ce
que vous pensez en commentaire de ce
casque de la cage et je vous dis moi je
trouve vraiment intéressant et je me
mets vraiment dans la balance avec mon
casque que j'utilise à titre perso c'est
voilà le casque sony en termes de son
les deux sont bien mais c'est vrai que
ma préférence votre casque sony pour les
petits détails qui font quand même la
différence surtout à 350 euros
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire vous donne rendez vous
dès demain vous embrasse ciao